На цьому кур'єрському підприємстві у Бремені працювали 14 українців.
Вони доставляли товари для сайту Amazon,
однак за роботу українські заробітчани отримали, за їхніми словами,
лише малу частину від обіцяної зарплатні.
Одного з цих колишніх працівників німецької фірми ми знайшли на Дніпропетровщині.
Своє ім'я наш спірозмовник розголошувати не бажає.
Каже, вийшов на цю фірму через інтернет, шукаючи сезонну роботу в Німеччині.
Приїхав за туристичною візою і, як стверджує, легально за контрактом
працював у ній упродовж трьох місяців.
Зарплатня мала становити близько 1400 євро на місяць.
Пообіцяли, що збоїв більше жодних не буде.
А потім дивимося, що минає ще місяць, вже додому їхати.
Грошей немає. Ну, почалися дзвінки наші на фірму, на всі можливі номери.
Просто відмовчувалися.
То казали, що будуть гроші. Потім відмовчувалися.
Потім узагалі заблокували наші номери.
Ну, ми зрозуміли, що немає сенсу, поїхали додому.
Ми намагаємося зв'язатися із керівництвом цієї фірми.
- "Ваш абонент тимчасово недоступний".
Не дивно: підриємство вже оголосило себе банкрутом.
Що ж тепер робити українцям?
Ми запитуємо про це Пьотра Мазурека з Федерації німецьких профспілок.
Він переглядає свідчення чоловіка з Нікополя та вивчає його документи.
Експерт каже: це поширена схема.
Великі підприємства залучають субпідрядників.
Ті ж або не платять людям за роботу, або платять не все.
Велике підприємство радіє, якщо може делегувати роботу і за неї треба менше платити.
Субпідрядники мають величезну перевагу:
вони беруть замовлення, наймають людей та обіцяють їм набагато більше,
ніж вони у змозі заплатити.
Це автоматично призводить до того, що робітників використовують, а грошей не платять.
У даному разі замовником послуг виступав онлайн-магазин Amazon.
Чоловік розповідає, що розвозив товари 12 годин на день, 6 днів на тиждень.
Пьотр Мазурек намагається допомогти українським заробітчанам
повернути зароблене. Спільно з ними він пише
листи-застереження та готовий у разіпотреби судитися з фірмами.
Наше завдання полягає не в тому, аби довести судову суперечку до завершення.
Ми хочемо лише дати поштовх, морально підтримати цих людей,
налаштувати їх боротися за власні інтереси.
Ці працівники мусять усвідомити свої права: так не годиться,
що нам не платять зарплату, ми маємо однакові права з німецькими працівниками.
Звісно, українці - не єдині, кого заманюють на роботу до Німеччини
та позбавляють чесно зароблених грошей.
Цей чоловік із Боснії й Герцеговини підробляє
будівельником у Штутгарті на різних об'єктах.
Йому ніколи не доплачували за переробіток.
За його підрахунками, він недоотримав 8 тисяч євро.
Він також шукає допомоги в німецьких профспілках і отримує тут консультацію.
Я вже не знаю, про яку суму йдеться.
Знаю лише, що було десять субот, у які я тут працював,
і точно жодного разу мені за це не заплатили.
Тепер необхідно встановити, про яку фірму-працедавця йдеться,
та знайти її юридичну адресу. Доказом повинні слугувати
розрахунки бухгалтерії, однак на першому етапі взагалі не ясно,
як саме називався цей субпідрядник.
Більшість не отримують свою зарплатню ось через що.
Довго встановлюється фірма-субпідрядник, а далі з'ясовується,
що у неї ще одне підприємство-субпідрядник, а у того - ще одне,
і так довгий ланцюжок з 10 фірм. А лише тоді - основне підприємство-замовник.
Українцям їхня бременська фірма завинила,
судячи з їхніх розрахунків, у сумі понад 20 тисяч євро.
Особливо у такі пастки потрапляють працівники з країн, які не входять до Євросоюзу.
Чимало вражаючих пропозицій роботи у Німеччині анонсується в інтернеті.
Часто це доставка товарів, гастрономія  або будівництво.
Зазвичай йдеться про некваліфіковану роботу.
Не треба знати мову, зате пропонують підозріло солідні зарплати.
Згадані 14 українців працювали у Німеччині ще до початку пандемії коронавірусу.
Наразі через пандемію коронавірусу в'їзд українцям до Німеччини
за біометричними паспортами узагалі заборонено,
тож не варто спокушатися на обіцянки фірм із працевлаштування та перевізників.
Про це застерігає й посольство України в Німеччині.
Нерідко слабкість українців у захисті їхніх прав - у тому, що
вони користуються "безвізом" для заробітків, влаштовуючись на роботу нелегально.
А згодом, повернувшись додому і побоюючись покарання
чи заборони на в'їзд в ту ж Німеччину знову,
готові пожертвувати навіть кровно заробленим.
Фірмам-шахраям про це добре відомо.